you can find that from any um mess that
you've had in your life if you just take
a moment to
um
look at it from a different perspective
and
um to appreciate
even the small things that were were
good nuggets of wisdom in those hard
times
hannah brown opens up like never before
in her new memoir god bless this mess
out now
god bless america now we're breaking
down the five biggest bombshells
starting with her time as the
bachelorette hannah says she knew her
husband wasn't there just hours into
filming
to a
start a wonderful night in the beginning
of an amazing
imperfect
adventure to find true love cheers
after appearing on colton underwood's
season of the bachelor hannah was tapped
to be the next bachelorette and was
hopeful she'd find the one but on night
one of filming she was convinced that
her man just wasn't in the room quote
when the guys were all inside that's
when i thought i don't think he's here
but hannah carried on adding that the
further down the line she got the more
she quote convinced herself there was
really something there with the men she
chose going into the final four peter
webber jed wyatt luke parker and tyler
cameron
which leads us right into revelation
number two hannah admits that something
felt off when jed proposed
hannah
yes
[Music]
of course hannah ultimately had to
choose between tyler and jed and well
she broke it off with tyler
i love someone else
i'm so sorry
and when jed got down on one knee she
said it wasn't the fairy tale it
appeared to be on tv in fact she says
when he pulled out the ring her first
thought was quote no i can't
but she said yes anyway writing quote
even as we hugged and kissed each other
as the goats ran out onto that beautiful
hillside in the gorgeous setting and
everything looked so perfect i kept
thinking this doesn't feel the way i
know love feels
fans will recall eventually the reality
star learned that jed had a girlfriend
the reason i held back details that i
did was because i was scared that if i
told you you'd walk away from me the two
split and didn't see each other until
the after the final rose special which
hannah writes was quote as awkward as it
looked
i regret all this so much regret my
decisions
and i wish
you know it was different and i wish
that i could change the past but i can't
but my love for you i don't think it
will ever leave me it's just something
that
is there
to stay
during that same episode hannah asked
her runner-up tyler out for a drink
which brings us to bombshell number
three
my feelings weren't
like cut and dry like i still had
feelings for him
hannah and tyler had actually already
been chatting before the reunion special
with everything that happens
with with jed and you know the really
early signs that like things weren't
going great i think i always like kind
of was like ugh dang it like maybe i
made the wrong decision and didn't have
enough time a few weeks before after the
final rose i i asked if i could talk to
him and was very honest about
how i felt was wondering if he felt you
know
anything still i wouldn't have asked him
on
national television to go out if i
wasn't you know hadn't had previous
conversations before that but that was
our first time seeing each other in
person so there was still like a lot of
like i don't know what's going to happen
soon after after the final rose the
alabama native invited the model to her
apartment where they talked and kissed
and the next morning photographers
snapped pics of them saying goodbye two
days later tyler called hannah to
confirm that they were not exclusive and
the next morning pics of tyler out with
gigi hadid surfaced in her book hannah
says that cut her deep writing quote my
heart was on the line and he broke it
with a supermodel that was really hard i
think i was really embarrassed just like
my ego was like oh man this
this sucks so yeah that was really hard
but i always say like if i had the
chance to date gg hadid i probably did i
did too
the two later reconnected quarantined
together with fellow bachelor alum matt
james and others amid the early stages
of covet 19 and documented it all on
social media
and while fans thought they were
rekindling their romance in reality the
whole thing was confusing you know the
public is like making all these
um narratives about us and it's like
you know i think there were feelings
there
yeah but the pressure of all that like
just it the combo did not work well
hannah writes quote there were moments
when it felt like tyler and i were going
to be more than friends and then he
wouldn't talk to me the whole next day
after hannah went back to alabama she
said she decided to tell tyler she
couldn't be friends with him anymore
bombshell number four she hooked up with
peter webber after his season of the
bachelor hannah said peter offered to
quit the show if she could say without a
doubt she wanted to be with him
i couldn't say what he wanted me to say
if like i knew for sure that i wanted to
be with him and i was like i can't i
can't make at that point i could not
make any decisions for my first year
that was just
a really hard moment for me
the pilot's season ended with an
engagement to hannah and sloss but they
split before the season even began
airing and peter called hannah to catch
up shortly after that the two saw each
other at a party snuck off to peter's
house and had sex but hannah admits the
experience quote wasn't good unlike
their infamous windmill encounter i mean
since it's out there and
you know i did say there's something
that peter and i did twice
it was actually
four times
[Applause]
quote i thought we were reconnecting i
was lonely but it wasn't right our
connection wasn't the same as it used to
be
after that he called hannah and
confessed his lingering feelings for his
runner-up on the bachelor madison pruitt
who he went on to date briefly before
calling it quits and while her love life
was full of drama hannah signed up for
dancing with the stars as a way to
combat the anxiety and depression she
was feeling
[Music]
which leads us to bombshell number five
hannah says those rumors that she and
her partner alan bersten were dating
couldn't have been further from the
truth writing that they quote had the
most volatile relationship of the season
by far we could be like love each other
hate each other in the next second like
we definitely communicate differently so
we we had a really hard time harder than
it looked on
you know on the show like we probably
were the most like openly would
would get an
arguments despite all that the two went
on to win the mirror ball trophy overall
like i wish him
the best and i know that he does for me
too but
i i think
it was important for me to show that
like not everything is how it seems and
like you don't really know
what's going on behind the scenes now
hannah says she just hopes that people
learn from her book that there are
lessons to be learned in the mess
there are going to be so many things in
life that you're going to be like how
did i get here how am i in
this
situation how i'm in this mess but
i think taking a moment to look back on
all those moments that you wondered why
to really
find what you've learned from that what
you gained
find that internal wisdom and message
you can find that from any
mess that you've had in your life if you
just take a moment to look at it from a
different perspective
[Music]
you